let's talk about this next story here
the headline from CNBC is Elon Musk is
the most famous guy in the world he's
dominated every story he's the main
character it's all we can talk about no
one can talk about anything else anyway
the actual headline is Elon Musk booed
by crowd after Dave Chappelle brings him
on stage at comedy gig I okay he was
booed he said it wasn't that many people
I don't think it was you know some
people are saying he was mercilessly
booed off stage I think the bigger story
is you know Elon Musk figured out how to
make himself famous and that's that's
that's for damn sure he figured out how
to make himself the richest guy on the
planet and then he was like no let's be
the most famous guy on the planet and
that's what's happening Dave Chappelle
what Dave Chappelle Brave and bring him
out for Chappelle apparently joked you
can't boom because he bought me a jet
pack for Christmas or something like
that is that how is that how Elon got on
stage with Dave Chappelle maybe he led
him on as the richest man on earth and
everyone booed I think maybe because of
that because they're you know envy and
anger but also I don't think he's the
richest man on earth maybe on the bus
well on the books oh yeah I'm talking
like yeah Putin you got Saudi princes
that are worth trillion I mean
an article that said Evelyn Roth's child
was worth 240 trillion dollars in night
in 2011. I read that article yeah well
the real richest people will never be
known to the general public because they
keep their wealth secret they don't they
don't want to be on the Forbes list they
don't want to be known to everyone and
they have a lot of assets and resources
and have they have more convincing ways
of hiding their money in their assets in
other ways that people can't track down
to actually see where they link from
there's a reason journalists that broke
the Panama story were essentially
assassinated and exterminated so um and
that was just one small banking
institution imagine all the
international Global institutions where
the big powerful people hide all the
king of England I'm sure I'm not so good
the Panama papers are you familiar with
them I'm familiar with them I did I kind
of thought that they came out in like
nothing like people were like oh yeah
they you know kind of like what
Chappelle said oh you know all the stuff
that you think they're doing in that
house they're doing and everyone's like
oh well I guess that they just do it and
then everyone just went back to doing
whatever radio silence yeah nothing to
Panama papers two weeks it like went
back underground or you said people got
killed that exposed it yeah the
journalist how many people do you are
you familiar I knew nothing about that
yeah that's that's pretty telling so I
mean who Global oligarchy running bank
accounts out of Panama basically
tax-free I think is the idea of shift
well the real people will money hide
their money right so and they never brag
about it they never highlight it they
never show it to everyone they never try
to show off they never try to be in the
headlines
um and there's a lot of those families
out there that that we have no idea
about which which I think is is
important it's important to note here
but Dave Chappelle also made a very
interesting comment uh trying to joke
about the situation saying that it was
only people in the poor section that
were booing him and then Elon Musk kind
of responded saying that he's uh Rich uh
and then said that famous slogan by Dave
Chappelle which he did on his show
saying you know female dog which kind of
came off a little a little weird family
friendly yeah well now apparently that
someone asked Chris Rock to say it and
then someone told musk to say it or
something the funny thing about this is
there's a conspiracy theory now on the
left where they're like Elon is deleting
the video because it shows him being
booed and it's like yo it's everywhere
Twitter is deleting the video because
it's a dmca violation you can't film
comedy specials at events it's like
being in a movie theater and filming you
can't you can't do it that's why they're
deleting it you don't hear you never
hear or unless there's something going
on like that little thing like you don't
see comedy events you'll see like clips
of concerts and stuff like that and you
know bands playing songs but it's not
like you see the jokes from uh it's
always the Netflix specials at the end
when they've already come up with the
they've gone out and toured and selected
the best jokes and put them together so
that way they can shoot the comedy
special the clips you see are the comedy
special of their best jokes yeah with
some comedy specials you have to leave
your phone at the door you don't even
let them you don't they don't even allow
you to come in there with your phones
yeah
that's like I get it man but it's stupid
because bring two phones like you if you
want to do what you can and all that
really happens that is
people can't access their phone to call
9-1-1 an emergency so it's kind of like
I think it's kind of dumb do you like
try and limit the crowd at All That
Remains concerts never no uh we're we've
always been a very uh well we've always
been one of the Bands that's like we
want people to experience the show the
way that they want to there's a lot of
artists that are like oh you know put
your phone down and be present it is not
in any way going to affect my show if
you hold your phone up because if you
watch people that are filming they are
almost almost never filming or never
watching what they're filming they're
holding it up and they're looking at at
least me if I go in front of them and
they're they're holding up their phone
they're not looking at their phone they
look at me because I'll put my hand out
or something and and so it becomes an
interaction and you know why people film
most of these shows at least my opinion
of it is it's not to share except that
they can remember it yeah and so they
can pop their phone and be like that was
awesome yeah and I remember being there
but a lot of people had this idea that
people go to shows hold their phones and
there's like a joke where it's what are
you gonna do no one can see it you're
gonna share that video no one's going to
even no it's for the people it's for the
people who are there to never forget it
they're taking a piece of the show with
them or fireworks it'd be interesting if
we could record each other at the shows
and then you'd get my video view I'd get
your video of me I would I've got Oodles
of recordings of other of people at
shows I mean we had we had we had a
um people filming our entire the last
tour we did was this spring we went out
for uh uh the fall of ideals uh
anniversary tour and uh we were out for
two months and we had film crew with us
the entire time and we were filming and
taking video and stuff so there's plenty
of video of people filming our guys
filming them do you ever take camera out
on stage and film the audience and all
that live Instagram all that 360 cameras
on the stick and stuff so yeah we've
done a bunch of that stuff it's super
cool a bunch of that's on our Tick Tock
the uh it's tick tock.com All That
Remains or whatever I thought this Elon
thing was kind of blown out of the
booing kind of thing was blown out of
proportion it didn't feel like the crowd
was booing it was a lot of mixed
emotions did you guys see the video Elon
said it was like 10 booing yeah and then
the left started saying like haha he's
lying and it's like or I don't know why
would he lie and they're like he was
booed off stage he's like no I actually
just stood there for a little while like
what did you think he was coming on
stage to do anyway yeah I mean it's not
like he's going to get up there and
transform into a Tesla or something yeah
or even make jokes he was just that's
why I'm like you know it's kind of weird
that he called him on stage in the first
place but he did yeah what do you expect
from Elon but they wanted this narrative
this is why I was complaining about uh
crap out of battery Twitter file
released on Saturday evening so uh we're
we're at Korean barbecue having dinner
and I'm like it's not it's not about the
fact that it's the like the weekend it's
about dinner time you know when when
Elon did the Twitter spaces on a
Saturday I was at Whole Foods doing my
grocery shopping and I'm listening the
whole time and I'm like and I'm tweeting
I'm like this is big news but they put
out a story the Twitter files that were
was like medium tier news on a Saturday
during dinner time and it's like okay
now you've just killed that story it was
it wasn't the strongest Twitter file to
begin with they put out a time to ensure
nobody would ever see it and remember
what it was and then the next day
Elon goes on stage with Dave Chappelle
if you wanted to make sure a story dies
that was a Master Class
and now interesting what were Saturday's
Twitter files again uneventful I have no
idea yeah I didn't look at them until
later so they they could have waited for
that news cycle for today
we wouldn't have had as big of a news
story I guess because the the next one
they released was bigger well my next
question is did you catch the Twitter
files on Saturday how were they weren't
they uh I I vaguely remember them
because we were sitting down it was at
seven something it was like 6 30. we're
sitting down to have dinner on a weekend
and then you know I'm checking my phone
all the time and I'm reading through it
and we're waiting for food and I'm
reading through these things and then
you know look try and remember what you
can when you are eating dinner that's
that's the thing it's not just about
being on the weekend like when like I
mentioned when Elon did the Twitter
spaces on the weekend it was a huge
story what he was talking about so you
know we were all there for it a huge
huge Twitter spaces 100 000 people but
when they put out a smaller story on a
Saturday at dinner time it's just like
you've just executed the story yeah it
was a nice dinner we had though
um so good
garlic no I was kind of reading halfway
too but it was kind of difficult because
you're there at the table and you got
really good food and you're just trying
to relax and it you know sometimes you
just can't be glue to the phone all the
time and usually that's that's the
weekend is when people usually put down
the phone and when people uh especially
you know in the Jewish faith kind of sit
down with their family members and hang
out with them and and and spend time
with family and friends the big issue
for me is I would love nothing more than
to work on weekends and I used to but
anybody who works in PR marketing media
otherwise knows it's everyone else who
will not listen to a word you have to
say on Saturday it's Saturday so I say
okay fine I'm gonna go get dinner
I put out a video on a Saturday it's the
views of the lowest of any day of the
week it's that that's marketing 101.
PR's if you want the big press release
it's Tuesday at 11 Tuesday at noon or
something like that so Monday it was
Monday I think at 1 p.m that's a really
really great time to drop a story I mean
got it I enjoy the break I enjoy being
able to clear my mind not think about
anything political I might share a meme
or two but other than that I'm like I
don't wanna I don't want to get into
this kind of larger political social
psychology of what's really going on I
just kind of want to get away from it
all disassociate and and take a breather
mind rest it's similar with singing I
was given in my all a couple days ago I
was telling you um and then you just got
to let the next date it's got to do
nothing just like meditation because
this is this is this is my life as soon
as I wake up all the way till I go to
sleep like six days a week so Saturday
is my only day off so I I try to enjoy
it as much as I'm talking about singing
singing there's there's a physical
aspect with singing too it's there's a
certain amount of of recovery that your
vocal cords need so it's not just a
matter of
you know mental or or psychological
tiredness from from that kind of stuff
it really matters uh you know how much
effort you're putting in or how much
work you're putting on your your vote
chords and I think your brain also works
in the same way where you gotta we gotta
you gotta relax we gotta meditate you
gotta let's take some time off because
if your brain is always running running
but also during the day having some
meaningful time to be able to sit down
and be in quiet I think it's one of the
most underrated super powerful actions
that many human beings should be taking
but sadly aren't and there isn't even a
moment in time where a lot of people
have quiet they always have something
playing in the background they always
have some kind of TV on or some kind of
YouTube video on and I think that is
also distracting people from the larger
power of what is now also gut I think
your gut needs a rest from time to time
because yeah that's why fasting has been
has been found to be so beneficial and
good for people just like the muscles of
neurons and they need to rest the brain
has neurons the stomach as neurons the
heart has neurons the heart needs to
rest from time to time probably stress
just turn your heart off you know just
relax but I think if cutting out food I
don't want to give my heart any rest I I
I'm going to push back on that idea I
don't want my heart to stop well it
needs no no not stop stop but it needs
to be rested a little bit yeah right
just chill out thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time